they have these Sanctuary cities like
New York that they're now shipping these
migrants to that we're all paying for
Ashley stclair who works over at The
Babylon be she's been on the show a
couple times over the years uh she was
coming back from an event a turning
point USA event I believe in Phoenix and
she was at the airport in Phoenix and
check this out we got a couple Clips
here uh she found that they were
actually just as bill maluan was
reporting that they send these migrants
these illegal immigrants who we know
nothing of they process them and then
they send them throughout the country
check this out from uh the Phoenix
Airport I'm at the Phoenix airport right
now I'm waiting to board my flight to
New York uh to JFK and it looks like we
have a whole lot of migrants who are
also boarding this flight that the US
taxpayers are paying for this is what
the us taxpayers are paying for right
here premium seats on Delta that they
have people coming here we're paying for
this shipping them out to New York City
because guess what everywhere else is at
capacity so they have these Sanctuary
cities like New York that they're now
shipping these migrant too that we're
all paying for I texted Ashley right
before the show because I wanted to get
a little more information and she said
that you know she's done a lot of work
uh and actual journalism paying
attention to what's going on with the
border and she saw that a huge amount of
these people they have that kit we'll
show you a little bit more here's just
uh here's the flight she actually took
some video on the
play
sorry that was a bit more of them
boarding but now here's on her flight
she took this picture and here's her
tweet migrant place next to me in the
premium cabin still has bag from the
processing center a majority of this
flight is migrants bust in from the
processing center can Delta please let
all of their customers know what medical
screenings are being done for these
migrants illegally crossing into our
border for all from all over the world
and being flown on their flights I mean
it really is rather extraordinary if you
if you removed everything else about all
the moral and legal things I just
mentioned about the Border I thought you
know we had these three years of this
crazy pandemic and you know Co is a
thing and are we screening these people
do we know what diseases they're
bringing from Sagal and Congo and some
of these other places again we know
nothing about their Lifestyles and then
they're just literally think about this
you somehow they got to the Mexican
border from Congo Sagal all of these
other places right they get there they
get processed now they're in Phoenix now
we just ship them all over now they're
in New York City tomorrow well we're
going to show you what's going on in New
York City in just a second but then they
just show up in New York City do they
have jobs do they have family there do
they have any
assistance and again you wonder why some
people are a little irked at
this